it's the most romantic season thus far  Shay Mitchell spilling details on the  final 10 episodes of Pretty Little Liars  and that one year time jump where's  Emily gonna be and what can you tell us  about Emison you know the fans are dying  to know  yes Emison i mean emily has no couple  other ladies to choose from as well so  this is the most romantic season thus  far and all I can say is that Emily will  end up with someone who she cares deeply  about the 29 year old was on hand at  Marie Claire's image-maker Awards at  catch LA on Tuesday night the final 10  episodes of PLL begin airing April 18th  I can't spell anonymous for 18 there's  no whatever I get your point  you ruined everything that I ever  ordered 80 make you do there's only a  few pieces left to play  [Music]  Oh